yeah welcome to this video playing is
that 79 from from Finland and then
played him a couple of times and teeth p
higher sandal or something ah now break
my tongue here okay we got a queen
scampered with Bishop f4 96 services a
bit uncommon to smooth order Bishop C
fibers more more usual oh yeah this this
line is this line is rarely played with
eat XD 595 is the normal we have a
typical isolated Queen porn position now
thinking night your 5s right turn not
one hundred percent sure
okay so just just take it
on 93 93 is a bit a bit strange let's
take it it's not capturing with the pawn
this is a bit bit weird yeah but ok I'm
saying this about every move that he's
making that is weird ok um yeah just
might be 52 yeah nightby fire to deform
Gabi take some c6 was some simpler
getting to hanging pawns instead of an
isolated pawn this kind of isolated pawn
position without the dark squared bishop
just having this urn Bishop only six is
some quite passive I mean it is still
rather solid but stood by the passive
position you cannot hope for much more
than um yeah hanging around and trying
to trying to draw if he goes between
before I play Queen deform this is this
is important yeah I think Wendy for is
the right move the question is is there
something better I could also grab a
pond here on a seven
but rook be six or not I'm not sure
about that let's just play 24 this is
simple and good now we need to exchange
Queens that gets my night to d4 with
temple
so Queenie 494 now probably yeah you can
also exchange everything Roxy one rook
c8 this is probably the way to go Luke
b6 I think or something it's just bad i
play b3 and secure McQueen side we can
play rook c8 the only other move
yeah but just taking a look-see ages
probably right our weight maybe there's
a technical problem text takes rook c8
rook c8 bishop see at night b5 and I'm
threatening a seven and are threatening
96mm aha the scope this could be a
problem now we place this after all okay
question is is there is there something
better you know come on let's not we
like rook c2 and then a 3 B 4 something
also an idea yeah the night is aiming 46
which is a good square normally and this
position controlling some vital squares
but still less regressive satyam
yeah this is one idea of this send this
maneuver so now how to proceed
in fact I think I should take on e6 and
play rock t-72 playbook c7 next making
some progress I don't want to take it
six strategically the bad bishop but
okay it's the transformation of
advantages look 12 c 7 and then I'm
threatening to attack the night and win
on the 7th rank
it's possible that term the black needs
to play some drastic move here to
prevent that I was thinking about Roxy
six but and this is interesting as well
should I play G for first and then and
then the rook nails is going to d6 to e8
probably
yeah this is good anyway a4 no this is
the trick I take be 70 is going to check
here
okay i'll get i get a pawn and look 96
Luke d7 night moves and then Rock b7
it's not me it's not oh I completely
overlooked that this is embarrassing I
didn't see that at all Wow
I was stupid is dead
yeah to get into a worse position here
is really a really sick
yeah I just I just overlooked this the
simple capture check yeah this is a
drawing OH check check check hard Ron
yeah okay of course I must win this not
not draw yeah maybe maybe around here
this is probably the critical position
so g4 is better or Bishop d3 more yeah I
of course rook c6 i didn't i didn't
really appreciate and now i think
opinion I should probably take it yeah i
forgot about half to simply if i would
have seen that um I I would play this
one and this still keeps a very very
nice edge here because I'm controlling
you for now so I could can just take it
and he still has the weaknesses I
completely forgot about f2 that this
might be hanging something like this is
still excellent you cannot protect right
it's an edge I just thought okay let's
uh let's get this and and win the
endgame but I simply forgotten Podrick
f2 and this immediately gives black the
advantage being on the second rank this
was really stupid but better better is
p.m. to play G for Bishop d3 first this
is much better if he now goes rogue c6 I
can take and play something like that
which is basically a position without
any counter play I just get the pawn and
have the better minor piece
yeah this is this is winning 11 key
problem here was that here he played
well group b 6 is still a rotten move
Luke c to c 8 is just better but the
problem was that this is not working
which would be the most natural to
continue but this at the end loses a
vital porn and the game 19 p 6 root b 6
is really bad because the rook has no
squares I mean it's also it's pretty
clear that this is a bad move this this
is better but not much fun of course
maybe he was worried about this but it
it's not a real threat here I can just
just play something I take here there's
a 2 at the end so Brooke b6 is really
the move that leads to two blacks
trouble can even now you about be three
but this is probably all right yeah this
was really a good game until I screwed
up on f2 alright thanks for watching